[Musique]
quand on pense fort et business on pense
souvent que les footballeurs sont les
mieux lotis pourtant le sportif le mieux
payé de la planète et un tennisman et il
s'appelle rodger federer si le joueur
suisse est quatrième au classement atp
il est premier du côté des banquiers
avec 106 3 millions de dollars perçus
ces douze derniers mois il arrive en
tête devant tous les autres sportifs du
monde selon le classement forbes
derrière on retrouve les footballeur
cristiano ronaldo 105 millions de
dollars et lionel messi 104 millions de
dollars
neymar et ses 95 millions de dollars des
français il faut se rendre directement à
la 36e ligne du classement et on y
retrouve kylie ann m ba paix avec 33,6
millions de dollars 2
je ris je vous dis pourquoi pas ce que
tu avais claudine dans l'oreillette et
elodie me dit j'ai un sondage derrière
les sportifs centres il trop payé je
suis dit et roselyne bachelot on l'a non
là où il est il est génial alors rodger
federer doc sportif le mieux payé au
monde
il arrive en tête avec son 6 millions de
dollars alors il faut savoir que en fait
il a gagné que six millions de dollars
grâce à ses victoires au tennis ce sac
est dingue
il a gagné donc son millions de dollars
grâce à ses recettes publicitaires c'est
ça qui est complètement fou donc son
contrat exceptionnel avec une auto bien
ça voilà qui était de 300 millions de
dollars sur quelques années donc déjà ça
ça fait ça fait innovant et footballeur
cristiano ronaldo sont 5 millions de
dollars lionel messi 104 à la quatrième
place c'est neymar 95 millions de
dollars et lebron james donc le
basketteur 88,2 millions de dollars il
n'y a pas de français il n'y a pas de
français je vous dis dans le top 10 oui
j'ai raté non mais c'est vrai que c'est
et roger federer c'est avant tout
maintenant évidemment c'est un immense
champion il a gagné un grand chelem
mais c'est surtout une tête de gondole
effectivement il est mercedes ligne
barre il ya enfin ces incroyables rolex
des bons tolex regarder il a des
contrats absolument mirobolants et même
je crois qu'il a même un contrat à vie
est très rare pour les pour les sportifs
de haut niveau exactement il raconte
ravie en a qu'un qui en comptera d'ici
jean michel mercier
oui et ce qui est terrible c'est qu'il y
ait des sports qui n'apparaît seront
même pas dans les 1000 premières
parisienne l'athlétisme les choses comme
ça apparaîtront sa part et elle jamais
arrêtée face au 10 mai jamais jamais
permettre de l'athlétisme
alors c'est un très beau sport et de la
course à pied que c'était là qu'on ne
vienne pas énorme et ciba bien sûr quand
vous êtes si si si si je le regrette un
de l'organe messi mais bien sûr que si
les syndicats dénoncent athlètes comme
michael de michael johnson et carl lewis
qui gagne et des milliers d'euros si six
candidats devront céder millions d'une
rue mais dont les chenilles des millions
d'euros 6,6 parce que y'a des vous êtes
fous courrier scène bastille
l'appellation bolton vous dirai pas
combien d'etion bolt bah oui mais alors
oui les joueurs de foot à la place on
est sur les 1000 premiers mais
l'harmattan des témoins moi je m'occupe
d'un club de foot de nationale 2 là tu
devenir les deux le plus gros oui le
commerce à ixelles oui exactement et je
vous dirai des plus gros salaires du
club
ça doit être alors c'est un très beau
salaire mais ça doit être 4000 euros
voilà le joueur 4000
voilà brut donc voilà c'est le et c'est
le joueur le mieux payé du club donc il
faut arrêter pour des mecs qui gagnent
ces sommes-là ton a le même nombre dont
300 millions derrière et qui galèrent on
y a des joueurs en ligue 2 en ligue 2 un
trader qui touche cinq mille euros 4000
euros 6 bons sens très bien dans le
multi vivent de leur passion magnifique
mais sans limites de leur passé et en
ayant un temps à qui vous veut peuvent
gagner aussi 10 15000 euros et le bape
est celle inverse de fédérer c'est dire
que tout l'argent qui touche lui vient
des matchs et non pas du sponsoring et
la tendance s'inverse mais exactement
merci vasque à noter que c'est la
première fois que ça arrive les trois
premiers ont déjà plus de 30 ans la
sportive de ouakam et je pense que c'est
très rare ils ont plus de 30 ha parce
qu'en fait le corps évolué non pas si
regardez moi le corps des volumes et sur
laquelle âge fédéral à 28 38 38 fr
cristiano c'est pareil passé 30 ans
messi passe à 39 rogers qu'on embrasse
eu la chance de rencontrer
c'était dans un restaurant voilà et
alors il a été très très sympathique
vraiment on a fait une petite photo et
tout un amour très très gentil c'est et
tous les jours via un navigateur
maintenant il est très sympa il embrasse
bien sûr tous les tous les joueurs voilà
qui nous regarde pas ce qu'ils sont très
nombreux des joueurs de tennis à nous
regarder et j'espère que vous allez
pouvoir on reprendre bientôt elle bien
sûr le votre sport est normalement
roland garros en septembre
et ça je vous aime beaucoup mais quand
on dit qu'il a 38 ans vous dites il va
faire 39 c'est rare qu'on saute ageasse
on passera avant de 38 à 40 donc merci
au bizet je vous aimais bien